[Music]
Jessica Simpson has something to say to
all of the haters well something to sing
to all of the haters
just learned so many tools through
therapy after sobriety it was so
enlightening it was like okay let's
break this down and see how I can grow
from this how I can protect my children
from this how I can Inspire others to
make this leap of faith
God knows it's about
hell
on Sunday Jess posted a clip to
Instagram singing her 2020 track party
of one in a candle-filled room
explaining in the caption that she
needed the therapeutic Jam sesh to heal
adding that as much as she's learned to
block out destructive noise people's
comments still hurt deeply hi I'm
Jessica Simpson and welcome to my
daughter Birdie's room the emotional
moment comes after Jess was featured in
a branded clip showcasing her daughter's
bedroom makeover I was really drawn to
the geometric prints and the color
scheme this really to me is Birdie's
personality thank you everyone for
checking out the adorable room of Birdie
May Johnson people were quick to call
out the singer's changing appearance but
now Jess says she's learned to block out
the hate writing that the most important
lesson she has learned since getting
sober is that she can and always will
get through it I am capable of pretty
much anything I care enough about to put
my mind to I didn't know that I could
actually be strong enough without it and
really I'm way stronger without it and I
didn't realize I thought that that was
going to help me through life I didn't
know that it was actually keeping me
from living my life over the years the
mama three has been candid with E.T
about her road to sobriety she's now
five years free of alcohol I was going
through a time in my life where I gave
up alcohol and I wanted to like just
Journey Back to the person that I was
before that and discover parts of her
that I missed and uh parts that I was
you know trying to put a Band-Aid on now
she says she's feeling inspired and
determined adding that singing her song
has a grounding effect for her in fact
she says she has compassion for the
people who dragged her looks online
[Music]
quote I know what works for me and that
is to let go and simply sing while
looking directly inside the mirror
straight in my eyes to really see and
understand myself I can connect with my
heartbeat I am stable and strong I am
home
[Music]
I'm with you
it's time to die